each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so it's an experimental verification
it's part of Tony's verified software
initiative there are two challenges with
the with the case study what is perhaps
to analyze three artists for structural
integrity properties and that's a
challenge in the automatic static
analysis server of pointed programs it's
not what I'm going to talk about the
second challenge I will talk about which
is to create a rational reconstruction
of a free artist as though you had
developed it top down from an abstract
specification all the way down to the
existing code and the challenge is to do
that and in doing so to discharge all
the verification conditions completely
automatically needless to say I haven't
done that but it is the challenge that's
the objective and target of all this is
to get as closely as possible to that
now there are some active experimenters
there's Ches prompt from the Technical
University of Delft who's been verifying
free artists using the spin model
checker there are there's a group at the
University of Durham on and university
teesside in the UK Zhang Xiao Qing and
his group have been doing code level
analysis static analysis to develop her
invariants about the coat and then to
discharge those with her with a model
checker and a theorem prover Pete rohana
Queen Mary University of London and
colleagues at Imperial have an interest
in free artists and Peter tells me he's
going to have a doctoral student working
in that area they've done some
preliminary work to find out that it is
at least an interesting and difficult
problem there's some jersey-new no
oliveira at the University of meeting
notes in braga in in Portugal and he's
been using functional programming and
vdn to specify parts of free artists and
to reconstruct the development there's
David they are at the universidade
federal your grande do norte in in the
towel in in brazil and he's written a
bead specification of part of the top
level functionality
we're colleagues at the National
University of Singapore engines on dongs
group who've been doing code level
analysis and those the work that I'm
going to report on at York in the UK
which is collaborative with the Indian
Institute of Science in Bangalore in a
project funded by the British Council so
why choose this pilot project well it's
an interesting case study and just
incidentally it indirectly comes from
from Microsoft Tony and I organized a
workshop at Microsoft Research in
Cambridge to collect some industrial
problems and Richard Berry came along
with three artists as one of those so
it's been an interest of ours for the
last two years I think modeling and
verifying kernels is scientifically
challenging and I'll say more about that
as I go through my presentation there's
a large community of users there are a
hundred thousand downloads of free
artists every year which makes it one of
the top 100 out of about 200,000 codes
that get downloaded from sourceforge so
that's a large community of users they
like to say and I I think I believe them
that it's the de facto standard for
microcontrollers so a verification could
have a strong impact it has relatively
interesting functionality we find it
challenging to verify it but it's
actually a very small codebase only
about two and a half thousand lines of
code but don't make the mistake that
makes it a very easy problem it really
isn't it's open source and
well-documented at least informally so
as a verification effort if we could
find some errors that's what makes
verification interesting as the errors
that you find we could also make some
guarantees about what the rest of the
code does the requirements are
distributed throughout the informal
documentation at producing an abstract
specification mitre might help people to
use the other code more effectively so
why is it difficult will there's a very
nice article by go incline on operating
system verification with it which
explains why a colonel verification is
such an important task for the verifiers
and wise it's worth doing it's a very
good read
for me the main difficulty is that the
usual abstractions that make programming
a bit easier just don't exist when
you're programming the colonel we have
to implement our communication and
synchronization we have to provide
scheduling guarantees we have to give
some guarantee about interference
freedom for tasks and we have to provide
the direct hardware interaction with
device drivers and interrupts and and
clocks secondly there are many very
complicated pointer operations and
that's what really makes the
verification difficult that's what
really makes it of interest i hope to to
you as well as to me x point is that
there are 14 different compilers that
are used to produce code for the kernels
from free artists and that means there
are many complex configuration options
and extensive parameterization and that
makes extracting the code you're going
to verify very cumbersome indeed I gave
her a talker too ETH in Zurich and I
challenged some people in the audience
to perhaps to try to to verify free
artists I was talking about token ear as
it happens at the time but I was saying
here's another interesting problem I
know that Cristiano calgon Europe and it
very very difficult indeed just to
extract the code from the code base that
he would then use with with with small
foot which was the analysis told he
wanted to use on it no I mean you can
compile it for different platforms using
one of these 14 different compilers so
they're things like a min GWT compiler
and those sorts of things and but here's
some good news there's a cotton a free
artist that's called safe artists and
safe artists has been certified at
integrity level 3 by the Technical
University of Vienna for some important
standards now these are not standards
that insist on formal verification but
it does show that you can actually
certify this kind of code base in some
way and the standards are IEC 61508
which is a general standard for software
and electronic systems the Food and Drug
Administration 510 K and the avionics
standard do-178b as I say these are not
about four methods they're mostly about
testing 60 150 right for example is all
about
some things like mcdc testings so what
does free artists really do it's a
lightweight embeddable multitasking
real-time list of adjectives and it stir
has a key assumption that the targets
distant going to just have a single
processing unit it's the library of
types and functions that are use to
build micro kernels it's written in C
with assembly language for the
particular platform you're compiling for
its be ported to most embedded system
architectures and it uses a very small
very tight colonel only about four to
nine kilobytes in size really very small
indeed it provides services for embedded
programming like managing tasks like
inter task communication and
synchronization like memory management
real-time events and i/o device control
codes obviously divided to boot phase
where you set up tasks and communication
tools and then the application execution
where you you schedule and execute tasks
and scheduling is either prioritized
pre-emptive cooperative or some hybrid
combination of any of those three what
we try to prove cornelius conquer the
Technical University of Delft has a very
nice feasibility study of what we could
prove about a free artist and he divides
the properties into four areas which
aren't terribly surprising I suppose
about functional correctness is what I'm
going to talk about at the moment about
reconstructing a specification from the
code and verifying compliance with that
specification so you can advertise it as
the guarantee for what's free artist
does there are structural properties you
might concentrate on instead regardless
of the functionality you might be
interested in does it dereferencing and
in null pointers you might be interested
in whether it has memory leaks or
whether it depends on a particular order
expression evaluation at the university
of parma they have a tool called Claire
which checks C programs for compliance
with say the measure of standard and I
think that free artists very nearly
gives you four figures of non-compliance
right so nearly a thousand things that
the Claire toward would would have get
to so it's some it's very interesting
code you might be interested in
arithmetic problems like overflow and
underflow I talk just very briefly about
that in a little while the retiring
properties about whether or not a sketch
show chedule Don time plus or minus
Delta and about interrupt latency time
the time from making an interrupter
actually having it handled and then
their aliveness properties like deadlock
freedom for the scheduling mechanisms
and mutual exclusion guarantees and
fairness of the schedule now I'm
interested mostly in refinement so there
is some relevant work here Craig has
produced several very nice books which
describe refinement of micro kernels
instead and hand proofs to accompany
them and the kind of micro kernel he's
interested in is based on lab rasa's
micro see operating system which is very
similar to free our thoughts and he
refined from zeid specifications into
abstract type so these are not
programming language types of still got
natural numbers and sequences and
functions and so on in them so they've
got unbounded types and he doesn't have
any particular discussion of the heat
but even heap size checking and so on
and his descriptions are non algorithmic
although they're very very interesting
than on algorithmics of no mention of
temple properties now with Leo Freitas
we've taken some of this work and we
find it to to target data types and end
on burgers done something very similar
using ASM going client and his
colleagues that nicta have some very
very inspirational work on the
verification of the SEL default kernel
which is I think famous enough vo needs
us to need to mention it in passing this
is a high-performance microkernel the
emphasis is on that high performance
there's an abstract specification in his
belt hole it's refined into an
executable specification in haskell then
manually refined into a high-performance
see implementation the theoretical basis
this separation logic it's on almost
complete handling of C and that's very
impressive there's about eight thousand
seven hundred lines of code which is you
know almost three times the size of what
I'm talking about there's about two
hundred thousand plus lines of Isabel
hull I don't know for sure I just quote
the Isabel website and about thirty man
years worth of effort and the emphasis
is on functional correct
Debbie diab has this some beef
specification and yahoo eel in all of my
MSC students last year has translated
that into Z and then completed it
because the B specification misses out a
lot of the functionality all these
things you can download from the
relevant institutions you can download
all the all the code for the for the
specifications so you can get your hue
Lin's work from York and Debbie d-arts
from from natal in Brazil let me talk a
little bit more about what free us is
tasked transit according to this state
diagram the there's a currently running
task there's a ready queue and the ready
queue is prioritized so that the next
ready task to be scheduled is is one of
those ones that has highest priority you
can block on temporal delays or external
user interactions you can be suspended
for various reasons and there's an idle
touch that runs when nobody else does it
had the lowest priority of all and it
might have an idol task hook to run
something every time we get scheduled
when nothing else is around and that's
the kind of thing that puts a device
into a low-power mode that kind of thing
there are co routines which are for
prioritized cooperative scheduling and
all Co teens are prioritized and they
all have lower priorities than tasks
apart from the idle task so some
interesting ways of programming these
embedded systems into TAS communication
is based on cues semaphores and mutexes
cues are just FIFO lists accessed by the
tasks the items are fixed sized and
fixed patty in advance of scheduling
anything there's a default copy cymatics
which means you've got no protection for
things that are accessed by pointers if
you put a pointer in the queue you can't
guarantee that the thing you're pointing
to remains the same during the lifetime
roots of its existence in the in the
queue or that the ownership stays the
same either tasks can wait for insertion
or deletion or for space in the queue
and this can all be used as a kind of
synchronization technique so semaphores
are
h22 Sypek pub semaphores aphids
synchronization between tasks and
interrupts so a semaphore is just a
simple tune or empty queue with a
relevant content and the P operation on
me on the semaphore is to empty the
queue and of course that can block if
the if the queues already empty and the
V operation is to have an interrupt fill
the queue so this is a communication
between a task in there and an interrupt
and the mutex as I was saying is
actually a binary simmer for that's
attached to a particular shared resource
for real-time aspects it's interesting
you look through the code over of free
artists and you don't see real-time
mentioned except in one very small place
so real time is offered by the micro to
the microcontrollers internal timer
offering a periodic interrupts and free
artist counts these interrupts and this
allows it to to offer a delay mechanism
and a task preemption facility when it
does that it does it by just doing a
little bit of arithmetic and so it it
assumes a default of a 32 kilohertz some
clock and in the in the configuration
file you might specify what your desired
tick rate is say 1 kilohertz and then in
a particular register you'll just do
that little bit of division and one of
the one of the famous errors in in in in
free our toast is to get that wrong and
to have under flow or overflow on the on
the arithmetic and get an erroneous
value in very strange clock behavior
memory organization well the kernel
allocates memory just before the
scheduling starts for all the all the
tasks and and cues so they can do
dynamic scheduling within that
allocation so it's a big byte array
which is essentially a heap and it is
used for task stacks and queues and the
remaining Ram has to hold all the static
and and global variables typically we're
talking about very small devices only
about 10 kilobytes and free artists prep
grammars talk about the goldilocks
configuration that you get the heat not
too big and not too small if you make it
too big then the program might not can
park you don't have room for the rest of
the static variables and if you get too
small you get to compile it but during
runtime you can't allocate the the
tark's task stacks why is that
interesting
well it's a configuration matter and so
it implies additional correctness
criteria which actually aren't visible
in the code at all but you have to stand
back from the code and understand what
it is you're trying to do to to verify
and that's true for all sorts of
configurations about about free artists
of which this is one particular example
so we just talked about pointers in
program refinement this part of the
project part that I've been mostly
involved in was to choose a pointer
model for the free artists refinement
develop some idealized code for the main
data structure which is a priority queue
and compare it with the existing cute
with the existing code and then
reconstruct a rational development of
how the code got to be as it is now that
there are four candidates we could have
for that pointer model we could have a
naive pointer model it takes a holistic
view of storage a bit like straight
cheese to level model we could have an
abstract showing model a bit like the
the model of of Tony enjoy fun part
where they were they have a trace based
model of pointers or you could use
separation logic which is very popular
or you could use dynamic frames and
we've chosen to use the latter not
separation logic dynamic frames is the
the work of you ganas Cassio's who was
one of heinous doctoral students and for
his work produced to a theory that was
published just last year in my journal
and this this is a model-based
description of pointers fits in very
naturally very nicely with the notion of
refinement so here's the kind of problem
at resolving think about functional and
framing requirement suppose you've got a
specification see that just says
increment X and then you've got a
context for that where you're
manipulating y y becomes zero and then
do is as C specifies what can you say
after see about why well in a non
modular setting you might lift see to
add the other variables suppose they're
exactly y and z you say the rest of the
variables stay the same in a modular
setting you might actually try to be
anonymous about what the rest of the
state is and you say well I'll ensure a
post condition that X gets incremented
and the only
I'll modify is X so here's an example of
that kind of thing here's a
specification and it's refinement which
are two modules the specification has a
ghost variable a specification variable
s which is a set of numbers a set of
integers two operations in certain find
insert make sure that X goes into the
set find keeps the set constant and
returns whether or not x is in the set
and then the refinement has a program
variable which is a list of integers
that's in that's used to implement s so
there's the the specification variable s
also included and what's essentially a
retrieve relation between the two it
says you can retrieve ghost variable s
if you take the list X and collect all
the elements in the range of of the
sequence and put them in the set and
that's your abstract set so there's the
kind of retrieve relation for the
correctness of the refinement the insert
the more concrete insert ensures that X
goes on the front of the list and the
the find operation keeps the list
constant and that implies that the ghost
variables also constant and returns
whether or not you can find an index
that indexes the element in your list
now the problem that's being solved in
in dynamic frames is the problem of
abstract aliasing so the framing
requirement for the insert operation the
abstract one is that it modifies s now
you translate that into a wider context
suppose the rest of the variables are X
and Y so it keeps decks & Y constant now
that translations unsound in the
presence of pointers because what if the
representation of either of those
variables X or Y share locations with
the the representation of s what's going
to be L in the refinement and that's the
unsoundness I'm talking about so there
are two solutions to the abstract
aliasing problem one is to impose
restrictions that avoid the problem and
the other is to make the problem a
first-class a first class citizen and
say well the abstract aliasing problem I
can specify and then I can say and I
don't want it and that's the approach of
of dynamic frames Pedro her likes to say
when he teases me about not using
separation logic he likes to say that
what I'm doing is working in the cement
of separation logic I think that's true
dynamic frames could be viewed in that
way there are some things that make it a
little bit more general some things that
yanis Cassio's claims giant which I
agree with but essentially dynamic
frames fits in very nicely with the
model-based specifications that I like
to write so here's just the methodology
of dynamic frames suppose you've got a
set of an infinite set of locations lock
an infinite set of values Val and that a
region is any set of locations now store
functions are going to be finite
functions from locks to Val and a
particular store little Sigma is going
to be one of those store expressions are
going to have the named Sigma in their
alphabet store relations are going to
have the name Sigma and the name Sigma
dash in their alphabet the used
locations are just the domain of that
storage look at that storage function
Sigma and young used locations just the
compliment of that I need a little bit
of notation that's what I'm leading up
to this Greek letters I is the preserves
operator and it says if you take if you
take the storage mapping Sigma and
restrict it to the the set of locations
f then that part of the storage map
doesn't change and that's what this
notation is doing here this is a domain
restriction that's a function that's a
subset of the domain and so we just take
this portion of the storage mapping and
it doesn't change between the before
version and the after version so what
IIF means is that we don't touch the
locations in F the modifiers operator
this Delta is what can be changed what
we have license to change in the
specification and so Delta F says the
complement of F is untouched two are
allowed to touch the things in F we
touch only the things in F while I'm
really up to is this theorem which is
which encapsulate the methodology of
dynamic frames there's a litte more
notation suppose F is a region so it's a
set of locations in store suppose ears
an expression it depends on variables
and they have values recorded by the
store so it depends on Sigma which say
that F frames e so this set of locations
frames II just in case for every after
store Sigma dash if we don't touch any
of the things in F then he remains
constant so we've got enough locations
there to talk about the constancy of the
expression right five minutes right so
Ian Dion Sigma independent if we can
find two frames for them that are
disjoint and so my theorem now is if we
touch only the things in F and we have a
frame g for the expression d an F and G
are disjoint then of course d will
remain constant right we'd be able to
partition the storage so here's the
dynamic frames method using that theorem
that theorem we can divide two parts
review rely on a guarantee condition I
think so if you can find F and G and
your interest in this expression d and
um as I said before you touch only the
things in F let's make that the
implementers responsibility and the
client will have the responsibility of
finding a frame G for his expression
that's disjoint from F so here's our
rely part of the condition and here's
our guarantee part of the condition and
from that you can conclude no
interference between the representation
of some specification you're using in a
library and the code that you're writing
and that's the dynamic frames method now
I've got three minutes left I think so I
want to talk just a little bit about the
specification and verification of free
artists and then tell you about an
anomaly zedd specification has been
written by yu hui lin a bit by me a bit
by leah freighters in a bit by xu chung
we've used Z tools and dead language but
we could have used any reasonable
theorem prover and any associated
notation with the refinement to code is
using direct frames as I've said it's
not
less advanced state was still an awful
lot to do but here's the kind of bottom
line from this book here's a property
that we found that has been violated
this property's been found by one of my
colleagues in bangalore sumesh a dybbuk
aaron and if you go to this part of the
documentation of free artists you'll
find this statement should more than one
task block on the same queue so should
more than one task block on the same
queue then the task for the highest
priority will be unblocked first now a
failure of that would imply a failure of
priority inheritance which would imply a
failure the way that free artist deals
with priority inversion which is a
famous problem in real-time systems so
I'm going to finish my talk by just
doing a symbolic execution just run
through a picture of the system here's
what the system looks like some of the
principal data structures here's a
priority queue right here the different
priorities and lists of each priority
here's the current running task and
here's a list of tasks that are blocked
waiting to send so let me populate that
here's the idle task it's called mange
got priority 0 here are four tasks with
different priorities and they're going
to execute some code and i'll explain
which one does which to who as i go
through so first of all main is going to
start the scheduler and that causes main
tubidy scheduled and the next highest
task to be scheduled in its place and
that's tasked one tasks one wants to
send actually to task for using this
queue and this channel which the local
data value but task for isn't running so
so nobody will receive this so it gets
blocked and goes from here to here
nobody's executing so we'll take the
next highest priority which is tasked to
toss to comes in it wants to do the same
kind of send but no reason it's going to
send to task for but nobody else is
executing of course so it gets blocked
and goes in this queue task three get
scheduled
does the same thing gets booked and ends
up in the queue and now task for finally
get scheduled but it does something very
strange it changes the it changes the
priority of task 3 and lifts it to five
and task 3 you'll see has priority too
so it lifts it to five now it does it
receive so it should receive from task
three shouldn't it is the highest
priority that's that's blocked right but
actually what happens is that it
receives from task one and then of
course it gets swapped out tasks one
comes in commits suicide task Paul comes
back in and does another receive
unfortunately it receives from task to
task 2 and task for gets swapped task to
commit suicide and finally task for does
receive and task 3 gets it so there's
something there that there's clearly an
anomaly here the the priority mechanism
hasn't been copied over as a kind of
added feature into the handling of this
queue and so that does as I say imply a
problem with the with the with the
treatment priority inheritance and
therefore priority inversion is a
problem in the system yes I have to
finish right so just just to say it
really is a deceptively hard problem
there's some interesting theoretical
results about with final with pointers
using dynamic frames and so on some
practical lessons about how to do that
kind of refinement so interesting
anomalies coming out and all the things
we do are repeatable you can compile
free artists you can use our main code
do that and you can watch that priority
problem happen it's not something that's
just in the in the presentation and
can't be reconstructed and if you want
to know more about this I've got a half
a dozen lectures at the UN summer school
in South Africa in in August 2011
what I'm doing that does everyone to ask
a question joy moment and they're
absolutely fair comments and I think
I've gathered 13 important requirements
for free artists and I think in my un
summer school I'll do exactly what you
suggest any of anybody else oh sorry
ok thank you Tony so just two for the
next 25 minutes or so tell you about an
experiment called token ear this seems
to have been an amazingly when I think
back long-running piece of work it all
started actually about nine years ago
and I prepared the slides yesterday I'm
using the principle of just-in-time
engineering and having kind of had a
feel for the audience that the about
this event this week I started with the
assumption that's probably quite a few
of you haven't even heard of this work
yet or before so I'll try and start at
the beginning of the story and I'll go
through the early bits of the story
quickly and then I'll get to what's been
going on more recently as soon as we can
so I'll give you some context and where
it all started I'll run you through the
back story of how we came to be where we
are most importantly we've got some
numbers for you I'm a great fan of
empirical engineering so we actually
have some some metrics in terms of
productivity and defect rate and stuff
that we can show you for the system I'll
then talk about what happened from 2008
onwards which is where the fun really
started because that's when we flung the
project into the wild as it were and
allow other people to look at it I'll
tell you what happened since then so it
all started a long time ago in 2002 we
done a piece of work for a company
called mondex which is now part of the
MasterCard organization we'd built
something called the maltose CA this is
the certificate authority for the
maltose smartcode operating system it
it's the root of the the pki of the
maltose smart car
so if I lost this microphone me okay so
okay and this is amazingly secure a
system it was subject to some remarkable
computer bytes than also physical
security concerns I think Jim you
probably visited it didn't you it was an
incredible facility extraordinary
facility like something out of a James
Bond movie and having done that we
published the results in 2002 and as a
result about the phone rang and it was a
gentleman the NSA who said would you
like to come and tell us about that
project come over to our conference the
conference is called hcs st i do
recommend it to you it's an excellent
excellent event in Baltimore it's coming
up in May again this year so we went
over to the USA to talk about that
project and at that conference the gents
from the NSA basically challenged us
they said well you guys think you could
build a secure system a demonstrator for
us to demonstrate demonstrate whatever
you want to do you know to demonstrate
formal methods or verification and we
said yes please we didn't think about
that too long and the NSA said okay
we've got this much money available they
told us how much money they had to spend
that was the fixed budget to do this
work and the subject of this
demonstrator was the system called token
ear we were asked to meet a standard a
particular standing called common
criteria this is the isos the current
iso standard for the development of
secure systems and it defines for its
own reasons seven levels of assuredness
or something like that they tend to be
these rating systems they're like a bit
like hotel stars you know you know that
a four-star hotels a bit better than a
three-star hotel but you're not quite
sure why so surance evaluation level 5
and above is basically where the fun
starts in the common criteria that's
where the standard starts calling for
formal methods and strong verification
or various system properties and so on
it was widely considered in industry at
the time to be kind of all too difficult
or nobody can do it all it's too
expensive and there was lots of excuses
flying around about why you couldn't do
that kind of level of engineering so the
challenge the NSA said us was to
basically prove people wrong to show
that you really could do that standard
of engineering and
reasonable price and then it was
technically tractable to do that kind of
work or at least to do the best we could
at the time so off we went the context
of the system looks like this it's done
it has some rather amusing terminology
it has something called a protective a
projected enclaves in English that's a
room and the room has a the enclaves has
a portal which also in English its door
and inside the door there are some
computers that you want to do things
with and on the outside of the system at
the boundary there's a fingerprint
reader there's a smart card reader
writer and there's a terminal that shows
you the status of the system so the idea
is you approach the system insert your
credentials which are your smart card in
your thumbprint the system decides if it
likes you or not if it likes you it
deposits a little digital certificate on
the smart card opens the door and you're
allowed to walk into the enclaves the
certificate on the smart card allows you
to do something it grants you some
capability or some credentials to use
the machines which are inside this
protected environment so it's a kind of
it's a bit biometric their tomb access
control issues and there's some sort of
cryptography stuff going on as well with
the granting of these certificates so
it's a nice little demonstrator system
one other very important feature of this
system is that it is unclassified it is
a demonstrator system within the NSA's
research group but it is formally
unclassified which you know without that
I couldn't be here to tell you about it
at all and we couldn't have done the
project as a British company and so on
so that was a nice starting point for us
so the idea was to engineer this
software in the middle here what's
called the ID station which basically is
the thing that decides whether it likes
you and whether to grant you access to
the portal and issue you with a
certificate and all that kind of stuff
it's a bit more complicated than that
how did I do that I don't know so what
we did was to redevelop and we specify
the core functionality so it controls
access to the enclaves there were
various administrative functions as well
so there's a guard role if the guard is
present then the door can be open in in
more States than if the God would not
present there's an alarm system as well
which may or may not be alerting the
guard of various bad things happening
there's
security officer role who's allowed to
start the system up and shut it down so
there's also very sort of role based
authentication things going on and what
you can do with the system depends on
who you are this kind of stuff and
there's an archive and unlock facility
with the system so that you can get a
trail an audit trail of what it's been
doing one particular constraint was that
we didn't have access to the real
hardware there is actually one of these
systems at the NSA's offices in Maryland
but we weren't permitted access to that
hardware because it sits in a place
where we can't get at so what we did was
to write software which simulated the
outside world so we write simulations of
all the peripherals and the outside
world so that we could build and run the
system on a desktop PC and also actually
have two desktop PCs one running our
system and another desktop PC simulating
the outside world and provoking the
system and injecting faults and attack
scenarios and whatever so it runs on a
pier with PCs connected by a network
here's a little bit more detailed view
so the pink blob in the middle is the
tis core functions that's the high
integrity bit that's the bit that
matters the white blobs are things like
the device drivers and the simulations
of the peripherals around the outside
which we also developed but we developed
to our perhaps a reasonable standard of
engineering but not as as rigorously as
the pink bit in the middle so we
developed both of those sections but
with the pink bit subject to perhaps
more more level of formality in terms of
development process just very quickly i
guess the goal was to be formal but
practical they NSA challenged us to be
as formal as we could be but at the end
of the day for their money they wanted a
running system you know they wanted a
specially produced code that you could
compile and get binaries and you could
run so there was a real constraint on us
to actually produce a working system
which meant pragmatically we had to make
some choices about how far we went with
some of the verification steps and we
didn't you know go for full refinement
for example because we probably wouldn't
have had enough money to do that so we
did the best we could knowing how much
money we had to spend the requirements
engineering work was done using a method
we
refer to as the reveal method this is
something practice has developed over
the years it's very much inspired by the
work of Michael Jackson's problem frames
approach and sort of adapted by my
former colleague Antony Hall
particularly with the focus on safety
and security related sort of non
functional requirements particularly
geared towards that style the high level
abstract specification was written in
Zed of the functional behavior and that
was then refined manually into a lower
level more concrete specification also
in Zed the implementation is in spark
which is a programming language
particularly designed for this kind of
system earlier today if you're in the
session earlier bertram described spark
it's a monastery which I think so
perhaps a little harsh but not close
it's a monastery where at least the
doors are open and it's growing slowly
we do we do we do have an intake of
novices every year that join our
particular conf lab and language is
growing and growing in capability over
the years does anyone know why these
slides keep changing I don't know in
terms of proof there was some proof done
at the Z level of at least one of the
security properties at the code level in
the pink blob in the middle we did full
proofs of type safety which is very
robust in spark indeed spark is
extremely pedantic about things like
type safety for things like overflow and
underflow and range violations and
absolutely everything and we did a
partial correctness proof of one of the
major security properties of the system
that was simply for reasons of budget we
didn't have enough money to do all of
the security properties at that level so
we did a proof of one of them so this
kind of just enough partial correctness
proof to establish that property and we
left it at that and there was a team
testing the system doing the kind of
intrusion testing and reliability
testing a separate company called SP are
engaged by the NSA and that was actually
done over the internet you literally out
a PC on the desk in bath in our office
running our system and another pc at
Albuquerque New Mexico running the test
environment and the simulation
environment kind of throwing data at our
system and an accelerated rate so that
was independently done as I said we
didn't have the real hardware which will
come back to so a few metrics to get
the bottom line the core of the system
the bit that's written in spark is
nearly 10,000 lines of code logical
lines of code there are no dependents
this sounds unusual possibly there is in
that code no dependence on any library
or any cots component of any kind it is
designed to run on a bare board you know
what we would call a bear board up
solution it will run on a microprocessor
with no operating system no libraries of
any sort whatsoever which is the way we
normally write spark because that's its
traditional environment the supporting
code around the outside was I said the
device drivers that talk to the network
stack that talk to the test environment
that was another four thousand or so
lines of code in terms of productivity
it was unusually high at 38 lines of
code per day that is a reflection of a
rather small team excuse me or go back
it was all done in 260 person dates
which is not much in the world of real i
quote we're realizing quotes in
commercial software engineering 260
person days is peanuts you know that's
three people for nine months part time
it really isn't a great deal of money so
it was done by two and a half people of
working two full-time and one half time
person for about nine months in 2003 we
did the whole thing and we delivered it
this is a defect removal injection chart
um we saw one of these earlier in a
slightly different format but this is
the defect counts introduced and removed
during development if it's not obvious
how to read this I'll give you an
example so the three here shows that
there were three defects and if you
follow up to the top left if you follow
up the left diagonal you come to 3d fix
that were introduced in the construction
of the Zed specification which were
found in system testing so the number
here if you follow up and down shows you
so ten defects introduced in the Z
design and discovered and removed during
coding so on this sort of diagram what
we're looking for are small numbers to
the right because numbers to the far
right of this diagram are both
embarrassing and expensive they cost a
lot to fix and they tend to be
embarrassing if they discovered
late in the day and we're looking for
small numbers on this final diagonal
because these ones are weekend expensive
to fix later in the process so there
were 54 total found during development
eight of which we would have considered
to be later than we would have liked so
the eight which are here to three two
and one were considered to be you know
rather expensive in that regard but they
were at least found during development
before we deliver the system what
happened after we delivered it the
independent test team found no bucks and
they did throw a lot of test cases that
they threw about four years worth of
usage at it and at an accelerated rate
you know they said well what would
happen if you know for the system over
about a four year period okay we'll run
that many test cases through the system
an accelerated rate our customers at the
NSA for four years did not report any
bugs in the system they did look we know
they looked because we used to get
emails from one of the guys there saying
I think I've broken one of your proofs
that once a month we get an email saying
I think I've broken it rod we found a
bug this would be followed by an email
from my team saying oh no you haven't
maybe from you know some assumption was
wrong am so there were some exchanges so
we knew they were looking they were
trying to reproduce the proofs and
trying to break them so that's good news
so far we then decided well we really
ought to publish that so we presented
the results at the HTS s event again
going back in 2004 but it's an NSA
conference for which no proceedings
exists and he's up known in the board of
publishing so so millpond to england in
this particular competition for for
producing a report that no one knows
about so we thought okay we'll try again
we went back to the NSA and we said well
how about we publish a conference paper
and we found a conference called the
international symposium on security
software engineering in 2006 so what
super will publish in that conference
and that paper was approved um at that
conference snake without a trace
downstairs in the demo fest area there's
the demonstration of the academic search
engine the guys at Microsoft to put
together that's why I know I'll look for
it
search engine it's not there this
conference proceedings is not even
indexed it's not on google scholar it's
not on microsoft academic page so this
conference sort of sank without a trace
so the next idea well why not open
source it this came about the time when
the verified software repository was
being discussed and set up so why don't
we open source it this thing like a
crazy idea at the time the NSA is not
known but open sourcing its products but
we tried it we said well ok let's try
and I suggested this to our customers at
the NSA and a couple of years passed
until mid-2008 and I got an email from
the NSA saying we've got it the NSA
technology transfer office came to a
position of granting a license for the
product which allows us to distribute it
widely and freely in source form so we
were very very pleased about that and as
of October 2008 all of the stuff became
available excuse me I've obviously got
these slides on some sort of timer
without knowing it Maya my ability with
PowerPoint is failing and also all of
the tooling to reproduce the product and
reproduce all the proofs is also freely
available and downloadable particularly
the compiler is GCC so that's easy to
get from a reputable vendor the proof
tools are freely available from us or
from various places also things like the
Z tooling that we use that's all freely
available as well so we tried to make it
empirical by allowing people to
reproduce the result so what do you get
um well you pretty much get everything
you get the requirements the protection
profile the thing called the security
target is the formal statement of
security policies that we were required
to produce specs designs the defect
reports so there are defect logs for all
that those 54 defects that we found test
cases proofs the whole works everything
in source form all the software you get
the supporting software in the
simulation environment so you can
rebuild the test environment and
actually bring it up and run it and poke
it and play with it the whole thing the
only thing you don't get in the release
are the invoices because we considered
it at the time states deceiver how much
money we were actually paid but I said
it was 260
person days in 2003 dollars so you can
probably have a fair guess at what kind
of money was involved it wasn't a huge
amount sure you so in preparing the
public release something interesting
happened first thing was I found a bug
in it in preparing the release of the
material for public something I really
did found a bug this turned out to be a
bug of a mission by the original team a
decision was taken when the original
project was done to forego one type of
proof one particular step of proof was
not done at the time for reasons of
budget just not having enough effort to
do it when I reproduce the proof too
much later I did those proofs and lo and
behold I found a bug which is
interesting there is one failure mode
with verification tools and static
analysis tools folks and that's not to
use them it's a failure mode we see a
lot of clients fall into they say oh we
won't use that tool and market doesn't
find any bugs so this thing can happen
since we released it a chap good deal
mended it excuse me d Amadeus Pinellas
reported a bug by inspection he just
read the code and found an and that
should have been at all or was it the
other way around I can't remember so an
end that should have been an oil it was
correct from a data flow point of view
it was correct from a type safety point
of view it wasn't correct from an
invariant partial correctness point of
view so that was an interesting one
there's been another static analysis to
look at it called code peer pour over
the code that found a few minor issues I
said the minor issues in there they're
not necessarily observable bugs that you
could actually say well that's a failure
of the system but they're things that we
would feel embarrassed enough to fix
given the chance they're things that we
would fix so we consider them to be
defects and the root cause is all of
these are in the paper that Jim and I
and Jim's research student ma wrote a
few years ago that appears in Tony's I
have to get the word like Tony's fists
shrift book that paper is in the book if
you want to see the root cause analysis
for these defects it's all there for you
so there are a few challenges being
picked up by some other groups now which
I'm pleased to see some other groups
picking it up Jim as I said and M&A a
doll did some really interesting work on
model checking of the system security
properties so what you did I believe Jim
is too
up the system as a state transition
model of you know door opens door closes
person enters the enclaves person logs
in whatever and then to explore that
state transition system using a model
checker to see if insecure States could
be reached and they popped up one
interesting run the new Jim the fact
that the shoulder surfing attacked the
shoulder surfing attack is where the
door opens and two people walk through
the door and we thought ah that's
interesting that could cause a problem
and it so we asked the NSA you know is
this real and the NSI immediately came
back and said oh no no it's not a door
it's a turnstile and a turnstile is
different from a door because it only
allows one person through / token and if
you've ever been to a really secure
establishment certain ones you could
think of you'll find they have turned
styles and not little things like at the
sports stadium where you go to see
football big turn styles which run from
the ceiling to the floor with glass
screens and you stand inside it and it
goes click and allows one person to
shuffle through these things are there
for a good reason and it's to prevent
the shoulder surfing attack of people
nipping through and the doors open so
that was an interesting little
observation John night at Virginia has
been Rivera fiying it using refinement
from Z to spark using his verification
approach called echo I refer you to John
to find out more about that Paul Jackson
at Edinburgh has been improving the
automation of the code proofs by
translating our verification conditions
out to smt lib format and then competing
XIII and hikes and CBC three and Alto go
all these different theorem provers to
see who wins or see which one can
discharge the most verification
conditions automatically so that's
leading into some it to mean to some
insight into how we need to improve the
verification tools some other things
that could be done that nobody's picked
up yet and if you feel inspired we would
love anybody to try some of these
challenges better yet get your students
to try these challenges if you have
students looking for something to do
needing a project please try and we
would love to support these first up
let's build some hardware so we've done
this software simulation of the the
operational environment why don't we
build some hardware a little door
fingerprint reader smart card reader
build a hardware
that we could put in a lab for students
to use as an exercise in secure us offer
engineering or real-time embedded
engineering and you could throw away all
the support software and recode all the
device actually build real device
drivers for the hardware all in spark
and then you'd have a complete solution
and prove the whole thing I was very
pleased the Microsoft have already done
this for us and produced the gadgeteer
system because what we needs a little
modular platform for building little
it's a hardware and I was very pleased
to see yesterday the gadgeteer
presentation I thought great we could
use that to build a little token ear
model we could even do a beer board
implementation we get rid of the nets
the lr runtime and go straight down to
the beer board ARM processor and run it
on there so if anyone fancies picking
that up that would be a fantastic little
project to build and it even rhymes I
don't know how we manage that but some
other possible challenges prove the
remaining security properties as I said
we we basically ran out of money thanks
for proving the security properties in
the said and the code so let's try the
remaining proofs of the outstanding
security properties you never know you
might find they're not true and you can
you can win a prize or something I'll
buy you a pint or something if you can
find a bug in those things don't quote
me on that you could start with our
specification and just reimplement the
whole thing in your chosen programming
language and verification combination of
choice so VCC maybe or are one of the
other languages that we've seen this
week why not we implement the whole
thing and show us how well you can do we
really like to attack the automation
issue with the addition of the spark
tools that were in use when we release
the system we got about ninety five
percent of the VCS automatically proven
we push that about 99 percent by pushing
in some lemmas to help the theorem
prover what I'd really like is to get
that to 100 which the improver will be
the first to produce a one hundred
percent automated proof of this system
that would be a nice little milestone
and I would like before I finish to
thank a few people particularly the
remarkable team that did this work in
the first place I am
the actual team that did the engineering
was led by my colleague Janet Barnes
who's still with praxis David Cooper who
was very well known in this world a few
years ago unfortunately well lost for
computer science David left computer
science four years ago and became a
physiotherapist I don't know why but he
does come back and teach said now and
again for us so he's the only
physiotherapist in the world that
teaches Zed and a jet david painter who
left practice a few years ago and we've
lost track of they were the original
team I would like to believe a
particular nod to our sponsor and our
customers at the NSA who played the role
of customer if you like it's a really
remarkable piece of work for them
firstly to give to give us the job in
the first place to give to give the work
to a British company was very unusual
and then to follow through with the open
source release six years later took some
real determination on the part of NSA
these people know who they are I will
refrain from naming them SPR a chap
called bill who did the testing work did
a really great job and thanks to people
who having been involved with the VSR
Tony Jim Jay everyone else for
encouraging us to kind of stick at it
and get this material out there for you
it would have been easy to give up and
I'm glad we didn't so pleased about that
what I would like you to do next go grab
it just Google for the word token here
you will find the download material take
a look at it see what you think if you
find it's useful great I would love
people to do some science or some
experiments with this material and
please tell us what your upto we want to
get a community going around this work
like the free artists work as well and
that's fantastic and tell us how you get
on so that's all I have for you thanks
for your kind attention
yes
okay so the questions about what does e
al five plus means so the the notation
el5 plus just means the NSA said well I
but five but do six or seven if you can
in some areas we tried to go beyond five
as far as possible the details of the
sort of compliance with the AL five six
and seven is in the project summary
report and I can't remember off the top
of my head so his motivation for you to
go and download it there isn't an ALICE
somewhere of the various common criteria
objectives each level and showing which
ones we think we hit and which ones we
missed so if the data is there the
second quest of the security property I
think the main one we prove there's a
security property that relates the
presence of the guard with the state of
the door and the state of the alarm it's
something like if the God is present and
the guard is present and the door is
open then the alarm might not be ringing
I think is what it's something like that
there's an invariant that relates the
presence of a guard to the state of the
door and the state of the alarm system
was that one we attacked both yeah both
okay modulo there's an abstraction at
some point there's an abstraction that
says we believe the i/o devices actually
affect the outside world and stuff like
that yeah sure that was the one we did
there are about five others which remain
as challenges to prove okay we should
move on yes
thank you Tony um so I let me start by
telling you the story about how this
project started but before I do that I
want to acknowledge the my collaborators
who are listed on the left red Holzman
and Alex Cross who are my colleagues
alex is now at the Oregon State
University and then summer interns chang
who john erickson andrew gongju and this
work was done by our group the lab for
reliable software which is that the NASA
Jet Propulsion Laboratory in case you're
not familiar with jet propulsion
laboratory or JPL it's the branch of
NASA that respond that does most of the
unmanned robotic missions so you've
probably heard of a lot of the stuff
that JPL has done the two voyages which
are at the edge of the solar system now
Cassini which is orbiting Saturn Galileo
which went to Jupiter Mariners the Mars
rovers and there's a lot of excitement
at JPL right now because we're gearing
up for our next big mission which is the
Mars Science Laboratory which is the
next Rover that's going to launch to
fall mars sometime in november this year
and as you know as missions are getting
more complex scientists are getting more
ambitious with what they want to achieve
with these missions so for instance the
Mars Science Laboratory is aptly named
it's a roving laboratory it has all
these instruments arm the drills can
collect samples it can do 720p HD video
stereo video so so what's happening is
that these spacecraft are gathering lots
of data and the growing need for data is
driving the the problem of how do we
actually manage all this data and how do
we how to eat on as engineers building
the spacecraft design the spacecraft to
deal with that and one of the things
that this is led to is an interest in
the use of flash memory so the all in
the old days spacecraft used to use
record tape recorders and other media
which were which had some failure modes
and more problematically they were big
bulky expensive had moving parts which
could fail flash memory is very
attractive it has it's cheap it's low
it's high high density no moving parts
which is one of the big attractions for
spacecraft design and it's used in in
many different ways on the spacecraft so
it's used to store things that are sent
up from the earth so things like
configuration tables command sequences
which tell the rover what to do tomorrow
and at the same time the rover is
collecting data it's gathering
engineering data which records the
health of the vehicle at any time you
know the temperature of certain sensors
the state of how much current is being
drawn by the motors it's also gathering
all this time state are taking panoramas
stereo videos and so on so so flash
memory is needed so we need to be able
to manage all this data and we are going
to use flash memory for it so there's a
need for the software that's running on
the spacecraft to manage this and we
there's because there are so many
different clients with with different
needs we want a nice abstraction layer
and so the one that's very popular is a
file system it's a POSIX compliant file
system so similar to the file systems
you have on your on your desktops
because it's because file systems are
flexible I have you know fairly flexible
naming schemes they're well understood
interfaces and so they're easy to do for
clients to to use now the what so this
problem becomes interesting because the
flash memory has certain characteristics
that make it somewhat challenging to use
an 224 to build reliable file systems
and I'll mention those in a minute but
our involvement began when we first
started our lab there was a couple of
missions that were using flash memory
file systems and they were using
commercial products and different
missions using two different commercial
products had some issues with using
their file systems
and and so we this project really
started as the lunchtime conversation
with my colleague Girard Holzman and we
had looked at some of these file systems
and help find some bugs and we were
wondering why why why these are so
complicated the class systems are not
very big as you will see there about
seven thousand lines of C and so we
thought well it would be nice if we
should you know we r we r you know
people who promote formal methods so we
should really try to use formal methods
to build a good reliable file system and
see you know why is it difficult and so
they started off as a pilot project to
study how to apply formal methods in the
context of spacecraft software
development and well fortunately
unfortunately it word got around a
little bit at JPL and we got approached
by a by a team that was building
something called the multi-mission
architecture platform which was supposed
to be this reusable software platform
for used that JPL missions we're going
to use and these and they basically
suggested to us well if you're willing
to implement this file system according
to our needs will include it in our
platform and of course that was too good
an opportunity for us to pass up but
that offer came with some strings
attached and the strings were it has to
be implemented at sea it has to
integrate as part of a much larger
platform they were building it had to
obey their flight coding guidelines
which meant they have certain rules and
plates when you build spacecraft
software flight software you have to
follow certain rules like known dynamic
memory allocation no recursion which you
can imagine in a file system makes it a
little bit more challenging and also and
the big kicker for us was we had to
because now we are part of a project
that has to deliver certain capabilities
at certain schedule we had to deliver
functionality at certain data you know
certain functionality at certain
well-defined time points and then the
next thing that happened was the Mars
Science Laboratory mission was it was
ramping up and I'm getting ready to
build their software and then they asked
if they were interested and they offered
that they would use our file system and
then it became much more it became more
real I guess and so what started off
essentially as you know a nice pilot
project hit the you know the the wall of
reality and and you will see how we have
tried to deal with that while still
trying to achieve some level of
reliability nowadays our hope was to
build a flash file system that would be
used by by JP it would be a capability
that JPL would have so so we are now in
discussions with a future mission which
is going to launch in 2014 and they're
probably going to use a version of this
so um before I before I go on to
describing more details let me say as
Tony mentioned this we describe this
once we realize this was an interesting
problem we you know proposed it and and
there's been there was previous work on
this all the way back to the late 1980s
when Carol Morgan and Vinod sufren had
written a specification of the UNIX file
system and Zedd and then after that
there's been a lot of work and i'm not
going to go through the list i've listed
here a bunch of names in orange which
have been related to the verified
software initiative and he's a lot of
people and they may be some more work
this is I think a list as of a year and
a half ago and so a lot of interesting
work and in many cases some of these
people have been much more ambitious
than us and as I said for us stahma far
our ambitions have been constrained by
the need to meet project deadlines and
to produce something on schedule and
changing requirements so let me say a
little bit more about why a flash file
system is interesting and to do that let
me first describe flash some
characteristics of flash memory that
make that make it an interesting and
challenging problem so here they are so
you can think of a flash device as being
essentially a an array of blocks and
each block is an array of pages
think of it as a two-dimensional array
of pages and really there are three
interesting operations there's an
operation called read page where you can
read a single page you can write a page
and now there's a constraint here you
can only write to a page that has been
erased and and how do you erase a page
you have to use an operation collie race
but unfortunately an irate operation
doesn't erase a single pages it raises
an entire block and if you try to write
over write a page that has already been
written you get corruption so and
essentially you can imagine that that
causes have oh so now if you if you go
and think about this a little bit you'll
see and I'll mention in a minute how
this influences the design of the file
system now if that weren't bad enough
theirs there are some additional
constraints it turns out that blocks
have limited lifetime so you can only
raise a block so many times before it
starts to degrade and typically this for
modern devices the lifetimes are of the
order of 100,000 or a million erase
cycles after which the block start
becoming very unreliable so what you
really want to avoid is erasing one
particular block many many times if you
want to increase a lifetime of the
device overall and maintain its capacity
then you really want to spread the
rights around as much as possible the
erase cycles around as much as possible
and that's a procedure called wear
leveling and that's one of the things
that you have to do with flash file
systems so so why are flash file system
so hard so the if you think back to what
traditional file systems do traditional
power systems store filesystem metadata
so when you boot up a computer it looks
to the media to reconstruct what the
file system structure is and typically
traditional file systems use these
things called super blocks which are
stored at fixed locations and and they
usually store multiple superblocks in
case you get some media failure but
because there are fixed locations when
you boot up you know exactly where to
look the problem is and flash you can do
you can't do that you can't store data
in fixed locations and the reason is
really if you think about and that the
constraints I said before I want
go into too much detail because of lack
of time but essentially the the fact
that you can't overwrite something in
place means you have to you have to
write it somewhere else and and the need
for we're leveling which is to
distribute the erase cycles around
requires that you have to move data
around even data that never changing has
to eventually be moved around just to
keep the erase cycles evil and and then
on top of that flash because you can
occasionally get because it because
blocks degrade over time you can
occasionally get failures and so you
have to if you're doing the right you
might encounter a failure on a block and
what you typically want to do is make
that failure transparent to the client
and so you need to do automatic retracts
in certain amount of bounded
automatically try okay so this this if
you take these constraints together and
start writing tractor designer file
system you it turns out to be an
interesting non-trivial problem which is
one of the reasons we proposed it so if
you look at what the specification looks
like informally you I think you're all
familiar with what a POSIX specification
looks like their operations for creating
files and directories writing files and
so on our file systems has some
additional operations an interesting one
is something called create recursive
which creates an entire a chain of a
subdirectory tree and as a single
operation and room tree which removes an
entire sub directory tree in a single
operation we make some simplifications
because we are working on a single
spacecraft which so we are allowed to
have two we know the kinds of use use
patterns we have so we don't have to
deal with things like file permissions
links concurrency and so on um the one
thing that we do have to do is have
what's called Rick site reliability
which is that at any time you might lose
power and so the file system may be in
the middle of an operation and so you
have to guarantee that when you reboot
because we are talking about an
autonomous vehicle yeah we have to
preserve itself and so we have to
guarantee that the file system will
survive unexpected reboot without
getting corrupted and and then we also
have to deal with with media failures so
you can get failures while you're
writing to a blog page or erasing a blog
and in our case there
there's an additional feature so most
flash file systems have to be with these
our case is an additional feature
because once we launch we are that's you
know we've that's it from then on the
clock starts ticking on the flash memory
so we also want to try to minimize the
number of rights and our file system
tries to minimize how many rights it
does for any particular operation now
going going now to taking a formal view
of this the formalization of the POSIX
part of the spec is fairly
straightforward cattle Morgan and then
on to form as I mentioned it many years
ago essentially you can think of writing
pre and post conditions over the for
each POSIX operation you think of
defining an abstract tree data structure
that sort of file system is and then you
forgiving that tree data structure you
define every POSIX operation by its pre
and post-trade remember I said week
we're going to ignore currency now one
thing that you don't that there are
there are some caveats to pause ex the
operation can return no space and
modeling that is kind of complicated so
I want but and we do something else with
that um politics doesn't talk about
things like reset reliability but we
have to extend the spec to do that so um
so we have to define a notion of what it
means for a reset what it means for the
file system to be reset reliable and
what we did was um now here's what are
the first design choices you have to
make what what cat what guarantee do you
want to make and the answer is that what
we have learned is to make this as
strong as possible the stronger you make
the spec the easier it becomes to write
to do the verification and i'll mention
i'll describe that in a moment so in our
case the requirement that we added was
any file system operation if there's a
reset in the middle of that operation it
will behave as if as if either it never
happened at all or as if the operation
completely fully successfully and
there's an exception if you're doing a
large right if you're writing hundred
megabytes then you don't want to provide
that guarantee for performance reasons
but I won't go into that and then for
for block failures the guarantee is
again the block failure will be
completely transparent again assuming
certain bounded bound on the number of
failed as you can get consecutively
so experience so first we started
thinking of writing the file system
using you know a formal specification
language and if you if you you can see
that of you know as I mentioned the file
system defines a recursive data rates
there is a tree and the key properties
that describe the file system if you
think about the pre and post conditions
they all talk about reach ability and it
turns out that reach ability is
traditionally hard we most of our
verification is based on first order
logic and reach ability can be expressed
directly so you have to work around this
and that's that's a that's an
interesting challenge so we started off
by first thinking well let's do the top
level design so we started writing some
specs and my summer intern and I sort of
have this little you know challenge
going on and I wrote a spec using Leslie
Lambert's TLA plus he wrote a spec in
something that in some flavor of EDM and
then one of the things we ran into
quickly was while these specs were
useful for studying the design
decomposition and you know clearing the
design in our heads eventually we had to
produce C code and there was too large a
semantic gap between these
specifications and the actual C code
that we had to write and test and given
the constraints on on schedule mostly on
schedule and also on manpower we we
didn't feel we could really bridge that
gap very successfully so what we did
instead was after going through this
iteration we decided to build a
reference implementation and so the
reference was written by my colleague
toward Holzman it's about 1,300 lines of
see what one of the nice features of the
reference is that it's executable
because it's a see implementation it's
it's you can you can just run it and
which are as would see is it's very
useful for testing and the other thing
that's nice about it is and I'm
launching this too is that it
facilitates model checking with this is
inspector especially with the spin model
checker now why is a reference simpler
why did we choose to write a reference
in C well it turns out that we can make
the reference simpler
one of the things we can do is that the
reference doesn't have to deal with /
hardware it deals with perfect hardware
that you it's actually an array you
think of this being an array of pages
that can be overwritten in place just
like memory you don't have to worry
about the reference being fault tolerant
because the actual system provides the
atomicity illusion the real system you
if an operation if you get a reset the
reference only has to match the pre of
the post eight so you don't have to
worry about any intermediate States so
the reference can be very that
simplifies a reference and then you can
also simplify the design of the
reference because you can use recursion
for instance which simplifies them on
the code so the correctness obligation
is exactly what you would expect if
you're familiar with these kinds of
proof you define an abstract file system
state it's a finite tree with label
nodes you define a mapping and then you
define at state these state functions on
on the reference and the actual target
from state the target implementation and
they so for any state of either of those
implementation you define a mapping to
this to this abstract filesystem state
and then you essentially show the normal
commutative diagram for any state of the
reference if you apply an operation with
certain arguments and you apply to the
target then the state match and there's
a case where you get a reset than the
four state mats match either the pre or
the bowl posting so so this is all very
straightforward the you know standard
correctness proof so once we've
identified this and we built a reference
so now the question is how do we do the
verification and what technologies can
be used and so here's where we now have
to live with the realities of castings
and schedule so what we did was we
essentially think of you take an
abstract program like this which
basically says pick an arbitrary
operation with some arbitrary arguments
and optionally inject a fault which
could be a reset or a bad block failure
perform the operation on the real
filesystem perform the same operations
the same arguments on the reference
compare the results of the operation
compare the the abstract States and then
check some invariants on the real file
system and then keep doing this so
essentially
see if you can get a failure starting in
any particular in any arbitrary state
with the two file systems are equivalent
see if any iteration of this can produce
a failure so that's that's check that we
want to do and one of the things I'll
mention is that so so now what's nice
about this is that you can use this for
testing so you can imagine having a
randomized tester that's doing this
choosing randomly so you can essentially
iterate this millions of times and then
see if you can find a bug that way you
can use it for model checking and then
of course you can also try to use this
as essentially the the body of a proof
what we found was one of the things that
we learned early on was that if you look
at the order of the assertions if either
of the assertions that chicken that show
whether the file systems agree if they
fail then the the one of the invariants
of the file system should also fail and
if that's not the case in the file
system invariants are not strong enough
and I won't say much more about that but
if you want that turned out to be
actually a very nice way to strengthen
invariants so if you ever get that
failure of a or b you should make sure
that c is also failing so um so after so
we originally built a random tester but
then we also applied model checking to
it and so we use model checking we used
naturally the spin model checker which
is built by Gerard Holtzman who's in the
office next to me it's an explicit state
model checker for checking properties in
linear temporal logic spin is actually
an interesting has an interesting design
which which makes it convenient for us
it takes a pro mella unlike normal model
checkers spin takes a model and a
property and compiles it into a see file
which you can then compile with GCC to
preview it in an object file and when
you run this object file this running
this will check whether m satisfies q um
what's nice about this is that even
though those input language to spanish
Pramila because you are eventually
producing a sea program it's very easy
to modify spin to accept a pramana model
with embedded c code with fragments of
embedded c code which call make calls to
the file system and if you then link the
files
file system and the target and the
reference file systems to this C file
you are now executing actual in the in
the pro mella xplory in the in the spin
exploration of of your model you are
executing the real file system code
which is really convenient because then
you are you're you're not you're not
just relying on an abstraction on an on
a model but you're you're able to verify
the real code five minutes okay so now
if you are familiar with model checking
you know that you have to deal with the
state space explosion problem and there
are no really nice solutions to the
state space explosion problem they are
just some engineering heuristics that
you can use and we've applied a few of
them so one of them is to test with very
small finite models to reduce the state
space and one of this one of the what
this required ups to do was to make sure
that our file system was capable of to
be used with with small flash
configurations it it's surprising when
we looked at other file systems many of
them require a certain pretty large
minimum flash size because they were
nobody ever uses you can flash with four
pages and for four blocks and four pages
per block but if you want to really do
model checking you can get interesting
interesting enough configurations that
you should allow your file says to not
to have any dependencies that that don't
let it be used in a small configuration
so so that's one of the things we built
in from the beginning we've defined
abstraction functions ideally in model
and checking you want to define sound
abstraction function so that if you've
exhaustively do a verification you can
then conclude that the original system
is sound unfortunately in practice once
your system is interesting enough coming
up with sound abstraction functions is
too difficult and then we've used ideas
from context bounded model checking
which is we bound the number of faults
that can happen which is essentially
like the idea from that people have been
using at Microsoft for the counter
context pounded model checking um the
other thing that we can do is now if
because after
very quickly model checking runs out of
steam and you can't finish the state
space checking the state space
exhaustively we can still do
randomization so if you make the model
checker random if you make its choices
of transitions random you can say
effectively you can use it as a
randomized search engine and one of the
things we found is that if you use
unsound abstractions so essentially you
write an abstraction and you're not
you're sure it's not sound what happens
is that the abstraction forces the model
checker to stop exploding a certain
state part of the state space and
backtrack and go search another part of
the state space and in our early efforts
we had written a separate randomized
tester and and what we found was that if
we start using unsound abstractions and
using model checking we would get at
least as good coverage as using the
original random framework and so
essentially we've stopped building
random test frameworks we just use the
model checker with these on sound
abstractions and that's been kind of an
interesting experience we that we
haven't thought of so of course model
checking again and random testing only
gets you so far there are certain
classes of properties that are very very
difficult to get to verify in these ways
one of them is a resource leaks resource
links are actually pretty hard to check
or two they're very hard to find with
with with the exit with things like
model checking and random testing and
really for that you need more
heavyweight verification engines um so
we had done some I had a summer intern
John Ericsson work with jay mohr a visit
to do a little proof of a CL 2 and it
turned out to be surprisingly difficult
we were looking at a very small piece of
the code and he spent three months and
had a hard time doing the verification
and what we'd learned from that
experience was that the code was just
too complicated for him to verify and
that essentially led to a refactoring of
the entire code and and and we had to
break it up so with an eye to make the
make the invariance simpler we have not
reacted that proof but I think
hopefully we'll make more sex we'll have
better success so what I'd really like
to do next is to use the Microsoft see
verifier which Stefan has been demoing
in the lobby one of the because we have
started by using a reference that's
already written in C this sort of makes
it very nice very well suited I think
for VCC because VCC essentially the way
you do proofs with VCC is you write a
ghost implementation or a ghost
reference in C and so so that's what
we'd like to do the the sort of the
stumbling block is that using a theorem
prover like VCC requires significant
expertise and so to get making that
initial transition it takes a fair
amount of effort and I will stop there
since i'm running a bit over we have
time for some questions yes that's the
that's the inner loop of the spin so
think of this as a spin
non-deterministic choice which which can
ruin and amuse ation for so so we do is
exactly these steps so these are both
written in C so they're just calls to
see to see libraries one is a reference
one is a real file system and then you
call them and then you check that the
return values of the so bollocks
functions return a value you know in an
error code so you check the error codes
which is the first assertion the second
assertion you build the abstract states
that's right that's right with all
possible arguments which is by the state
space those and this is where you start
up to play games with abstractions and
then you also we also check in there and
so i can i can go offline why but this
is actually the certain properties that
can't be checked because you have the
abstraction doesn't model them